それから宗教と修行の世界
バラエティに富んだ修行の世界と人の人生
修行といえばものすごいたくさんがいますからね
修行の狙い 救済のため
幸福になるため 現世利益のため
死亡の安らぎのため また怯え恐怖感をなくすため
人は信仰を持ったり 修行したりするんです
大雑把で言えばそんなもんなんですね
現世利益は特別に日本語
日本での宗教目的ですけど
アメリカも優れたもんじゃないんです
もう現世利益のために信仰していますけど
しかし 信仰の数 修行方法などは無数にあるんですよ
信仰 宗教といえばどれぐらいあるかわからないんですよ
まあ世界で大きくキリスト教
イスラム教とか言ったりするんですけど
イスラム教の中ではもう無数の宗教があるんです
キリスト教の中にもものすごいたくさんあります
そんな遠く見なくたって
皆様の身の回り見てください
どれぐらい宗教あるのか
それで宗教もたくさんあると同時に
修行方法もたくさんありますね
まあ日本ではね 現世利益と病気治すですね
それで宗教 幽霊とか死んだ人と喋る人々いますけど
あれは地獄に地獄から立ち上がった人々よく仲間と喋るんです
もっと一緒にいた仲間だから
お前早く帰ってこいと
ほとんど信仰 迷信 神話に基づくもので
危険目は疑問です ほとんどの宗教というのは何か神話
何かを迷信 何か物語 それ使ってるんです
教えっていうのはないんです
学校で 大学で授業で言ってるような
何かこれだからこうこうなってる
こうこうなってる あれやこれやとかね
そういうことない ないの
物語 ヒンドゥー教でもちょっと読んでみてください
物語に物語に物語 全部作り話です
見ただけでわかるんです
ただ神話物語を子供たちに教える
それが教えこそ ヒンドゥー教の面白いですよ
神様がいるんですね シヴァという神様がね
その神様にお子さんがいるんで
パールティという 夫婦でしょ
子供が二人いるんで 二人は奇形児なんです
一人の頭が象 体が人間
もう一人の頭は首６本あります
手が12本です 名前スカンドクマール
頭 象の神様はガネーシャというんです
なんで頭が象になったかというと
あの 兄弟だから喧嘩するんですよ
そこでも誰が頭がいいんでしょうかと
ということで 父親か母親がね
あの これさすが我々が使っている言語では
このダジャレがよくわかりますけど
日本語にしちゃうと出てこないんですけど
あの七つの海にあの塩の輪っかワードがなんとか言うんですよ
それが七つの大海って目なんです
それは一回りして走って来いと言ったんです
喧嘩するんだからね そうするとスカンドクマール神がもう乗り物
車は脆弱ですからね サッと瞬間で全部地球を回るか
海を回って一回りして戻ったんです
ガネーシュという神様の乗り物がネズミなんです
ネズミにはね 海を回ってるできないんだから
これは頭を使って家に台所に塩を溶かして
ちっと入れ物がありまして
そこを一回りして戻ったんです
海を戻って 鳥に乗って戻ってくると
こういう先に来てるんですね
弟が腹が立ったんです
ズルをやるなよと  うん
でも言葉ではどうしようもない
言葉で同じ言葉だから
塩が入れた入れ物に使う同じ単語が大会には使うんだから
知ったものじゃないんで
腹が立ってぶん殴っちゃったんです
それで首が切れて死んじゃった
それで頭をつけとかないともうかわいそうだからね
で 親が神様がね 命令して
さっさとこう なんとかなんとか条件の中で生きてる誰の頭でもいいんだから
さっさと一つ持ってこいというと
ちょうどその時 その条件の中で寝ていた見つかった像なんですね
しょうがないんだから
像の首を切ってきて神のつけて
それから神様の頭が像の頭になってしまったと
で 真面目に信じています
でもどう見たってただ面白い話だけなんですけど
あんまり理屈知らない人が作った話でしょうやと思いますよ
逆に言えば二人とも危険人で
でもそれにまた一人で
なんであの神様に頭が 4つあるのか
6つあるのか それもまたストーリーありますよ
で 神様 地球屋がこの神々と神々と戦うアシュラという
グループがあるんです
とにかく戦うんです それでアシュラの一人がもう戦うことはしないで
もう神様に君を礼をしたり
仲良くしようかなと思っちゃった
神様はあんまり相手にしないんです
それでもずっとお世話するんです
お世話して何か一つ教えてもらいたくて弟子入りしたいです
敵がなぜかというと このシヴァ神だから何でも瞬間で燃やすことができます
森羅万象全部 だからその呪文を教えてください
これは敵に教えるわけにはいきませんでしょう
教えてあげない でも長い長い年月をお世話するんだから
神様もどうしようもなく
あなたには自分を教えることはできません
それは神だけの特権やと
しかし あなたの手に呪文を言ってあげます
そうすると力が手に入りますよと言って
手を取って呪文を唱えたんです
唱えたら この手でもう触るものは燃えて灰になっちゃうんです
終わった瞬間で この世はもうどうせ敵だからね
じゃあこれ確かめてみようと思って
同じ神様を触ろうとするんです
神が怯えて逃げるわ 逃げるわ
逃げるわ 神だから何とかすればいいのに
それはない 逃げる 逃げたら追っかけていくんです
それで地球を守る神は牛の神っていうんですね
牛の神が見たら あら この地球を破壊する神は大変なことになっているんだ
助けてあげなくちゃと
守る神だから思って すっごい美しい女の姿に変身して
途中でブランコに乗っているんです
そうするとこの敵の神が見たら
ものすごい美人でびっくりしちゃって
それで止まっちゃった
止まったらヴィシュヌ神もニコッと笑ったら
あんた気が合うみたいだ
それでじゃあ結婚しようよと
ただ あのね あなたにも奥さんがいるでしょ
だからダメ 私は結婚したいないと
奥さんに聞いてみろ よし
聞いてくれますか？だから走っていって
自分の奥さんにね こういうもうとんでもない道じゃないとダメ
それできないんですよ
あんたどう思います？と
神々の世界だから まあいいよ
と言ったらOK取ったんだから
もう走ってまた来た ヴィシュヌ神のところ来たら子供がいるんです
いや あのね 言い始めたんだけどね
子供がいるんだ だから奥さんに聞いてください
と言ったら また奥さん OK するんです
まあ子供いるぐらいで大丈夫だよ
来ると二人がいるんですね
6回目 行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり その間でシヴァ神がもうものすごく逃げて隠れて見えないところに隠れているんです
で  6回目 もうこれで OK とわかったところで
ヴィシュヌ神はね これは私のこの 6人も私の子供やと抱き抱きました
抱いたところ みんな 6人一緒になっちゃって
首だけ別に頭だけだけで体一つになってしまったっていう話です
どうせこのシヴァ神を助けるためにやったことだから
これはあなたのことになるとあげたんです
で そういう風な この神話という宗教物語がたくさんありますよ
ヒンドゥ教 面白いんです
まあ勉強になりますよ
勉強すると別に信仰するところはありますけど
まあ勉強すると結構面白いこと
もう昨日も一つ記事を読んでみて
どうしよう嫌になっちゃって
途中でやめましたけどね
イスラム教の今のハッジという
あれ メッカに行くんだからね
その記事を読んでみて
まあ嫌になって なんだこれ
あまりにも品がないというところでやめました
けど 面白い物語は一応あるんです
だからこの宗教っていうのはそういう物語なんですね
皆様にはいくつか馴染みがあるのはね
まあキリスト教でしょうし
やっぱり物語でしょ 旧約聖書は物語
物語 物語でしょ 教えはないんです
だからこういう神話とか
何か物語を信じて 何か修行したら結果があるかないかということはちょっと言いづらいんですよ
あのイスラム教もいろんな物語があるんです
ユダヤ教も同じですよ
たくさん物語があります
ユダヤ教の物語はまあ結構論理的で冗談で
それほど大きい問題じゃないんですけど
はい そういうわけで たくさんいろいろ宗教がありまして
宗教によって修行方法も変わりますね
例えばヒンドゥー教のこのこちらにこの 3色の色を灰でね
描く人もいて ポンと丸く丸いだけ入れる人もいて
あるいは U の形を描いて真ん中赤いんで
それだけでもいろいろいくつかあります
で 髪の毛を剃る人もいるし
伸ばして結んでおく人もいるし
でお数を持っている人もいるし
口で何か針を横にさせている人も
あらゆる修行方法たくさんあります
日本でも同じことで いろんな宗教でいろんな修行法があるんで
だからどっちがどうかということは
素人に一般人にはわからないんですよ
修行する人に聞いたらなおさらわからないです
それで仏教っていうのは宗教でありますからね
目的ははっきりしています
苦しみを完全に乗り越えるために
幸福に達するためにです
あれこれガチャガチャ言わない
二つ目的 苦しみを完全に超越するためになくすため
幸福になった 同じこと
だから目的はたった一つ
天国に行くためとか永遠の命とか
全然そんなこと言わない
永遠な命に命をいただくために修行するならば矛盾でしょ？今も生きてるんだから
今も永遠でしょうね 命が
で 修行しなくても だからそんなことも言うんだから
仏教はそういうことを言わない
生きることは苦しいんだよ
それは何とかしましょう
あと固めなくなくしちゃえということ
生きる苦しみに対して具体的に語るので
苦しみを乗り越えることも具体的な結果なんです
仏教は生きる苦しみに対して
誰かに罰が 誰かが罰が与えて人は苦しんでいるんだよとは
そういうことは言わない
具体的に苦しみ言うんですよ
子供が死んじゃったら苦しいでしょうとかね
あんた病気になったら苦しいでしょ
期待が外れたら最悪でしょうとかね
具体的です それで嫌な人と付き合うことになったらどうですかね
人生は 好きな人と別れる羽目になったら
でも実際それ一つも避けられないでしょうと
年取ることも 病気になることも
死ぬことも だから 生きるということは苦しいことである
汝は悪くて神を裏切ったんだから
そんな馬鹿なこと言いません
生まれてすぐ間もないうちに
ひどい病気で寿命が短くなったっても
そういうことだよ 見てることは
その子はもう寿命は 5年も持たないかもしれませんだけどね
で その 5 年間苦しんで生きて死ぬし
あんたは見る限りは 80 年間苦しむでしょうと
健康だから まあどうってことないんだと
五分五分や だから 白血病で苦しんでいる子供は
特別に苦しみを味わっているわけじゃないんですよ
まあせいぜい 5  6 年間ぐらい
病院通いにいろいろ輸血したり
いろいろことで まあもう学校に行けなくなったりして
それぐらいのことですよ
それでもみんな遊んでくれるし
お母さんもべったりとそばにいてくれるし
父親ももうすぐもう仕事終わったらすぐ飛んできてそばにいてくれるし
だからどうでしょうかね
健康な子には全然それないでしょうね
だからこの量が多い 小さいことがなく苦しいんです
生きることは そういうふうに具体的に苦しみを語るんだから
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている幸福も安らぎもすごい具体的なもので
今ここで結果が得られるということは
仏教の なんです 死後で天国というとちょっと怪しいと
今病気だから今薬くれと
今薬飲んだら 40年後で治りますよとはダメですよ
しかし 大体宗教っていうのは死んでから天国ですから
40年じゃないでしょう
子供の頃信仰したら薬飲んだのは子供の頃でしょ
60年  70年  80年待たなくちゃいけないんです
それでも天国はないんです
最後の審判の頃まで待たなくちゃいけないんだから
その日にちはもうぐるぐる変わるんです
去年か一昨年か聞いたんですけど
新宿駅でなんかもうもうそろそろ来るという話で
拡声機でもう間もないうちに
神様が戻ってくるんだと
その時はみんなもう大変なことになります
今はもう今から待ってる場合じゃないんだと
今すぐ神を信仰して罪を悔い改めなさいというふうな話で
私はもう忙しくて 後で聞く予定でしたからね
ちょっと待って この人にと思って
話しかたから話したかったんです
そんな暇がなかったんだけど
で 何年何月何日来るのかと
聞いたかったんです 当然そんなことはわかりませんと言うでしょうね
あ そうっていうことで終わりますからね
そういうのは本当にすごい神様が来るならばね
一日ぐらい先に言ってくれ
だって 自分の国の大統領
日本に来たんですけど
2日  3日しかいなかったんですけど
まあ我々は 3ヶ月とか前から知ってるんですけど
大した人じゃないでしょうね
それでも我々自分の国の人にとっては大統領だから
3ヶ月とか前から知っていて
いろいろ準備をして いろいろ計画立てたりして
帰りのスケジュールは全部調べて
ここでこれでこうしましょう
ああしましょうとか ちょっとこれ提案してみましょうと
だからちょっとそこだけ偉い人であってもそうなのに
まあまあ それに仏教はそこ
本当は仏教はすごくこの世間にある間違いに対して正しい答えを出すんだから
やっぱり科学的な具体的なものだったらすぐ結果出ないと
例えばこれから 80年経つと簡単に宇宙旅行できるんだよ
核融合できますよ だからまあ半額でも
これからそれは 1億人
1億円とかね  2億円かかりますから
1万ずつ入れてくださいとチケット売っても誰が買うんですか？それで 80年終わると
もう 2億円か 5億円となるようにと月々払う
皆様なら払うでしょうね
私は払いませんよ 長すぎ約束は
宇宙旅行 核融合を売れるのは
もうそこはもう商売始めたからなんですよ
たまに金持ちがもう機械作ったり計画立てる途中で予約するかもしれませんけど
それでも先にその人死んじゃったらもうそれは意味がないしね
だから結果すぐ出なきゃダメなんです
そういうこと このディッティは断念という今ここで結果出ます
それからサンディップと実証できます
ブッダの教えは今すぐ聞いたら
あれは真理であることは実証してみます
それで お釈迦様は実証主義で語るんです
語りながらどう？私は言っていることは何かある？間違いとか異論があるという感じで
それからアカーリコというよね
この法の特色なんですね
時間の流れと関係がない
ブッダの教えは という意味 2つあります
1 結果が現れるために時間がかからないということと
時間が経つと変化して変わるものではないと
世の中にあるものは何でも
時間経つともう老化して時代遅れになります
ブッダの教えはそれはないんです
そういう意味でアカール時間とは関係ないんだよという意味使ってます
また別な意味で同じ辞書で出ますから
あの修行したらすぐ結果です
即効性 それからヴィパッサナー
僕はすごい全然怖くない大胆な教えなんです
はい 来て調べなさい 全部開放オープンなんです
立ち入り禁止はまるっきりない
それにすらイスラム教っていうのはもう激しい
立ち入り禁止 立ち入り禁止
日本に友達がいるんですけど
もう少しなんか中に入れてくれないんです
外 外っていう だから そういうことはね
メッカには絶対入れませんだからね
イスラム人以外は このビデオとかいろいろある
全部イスラム人が撮って
王様から特別許可を得ていないと入ってはいけない
そういうのはないんです
それは宗教 政治ですからどうでもいいんだけど
教えに対してもどうぞ勝手に読んで
勝手に見て 勝手に調べて
勝手に試して 勝手に批判して
できることならやってみなさい
わからないことだったら教えてまであげると
という態度取るんです
それぐらい言ってることは事実であるという
この自信 それがこのブッダの時代で起きたことで
この他宗教と仏教の差を教えてあるんです
この真面目に書いている経典で 76番目の経典ですね
宗教にならない宗教は 4つあります
名前だけ宗教で これは宗教じゃないんだね
ですから 修行なんか成り立たない
真面目な言っただけで矛盾で終わりという宗教 4つあるんだよ
一 善行為 悪行為には結果がない
死後 遺体を火葬したら残るのは灰だけだという教え
何をやったって結果がないんだよ
善行 悪行為なんかあるわけないんだ
えらいなんか科学っぽいですね
人が死んじゃったら もう火葬したら残るのは骨と灰だ
いうふうなことをのこのこと言うんだと
だからその話を聞いた人が
これ宗教なんです インドではそういうことを言う宗教があったんです
理性ある人だったら だったらこの野郎何やってるのか
こんな修行したり 特別に生き方したり
こんなことをしたっても死後は同じでしょ
贅沢に溺れて下手したら同じでしょ
だからこの人の教えと宗教
教は無意味ですと この人から学ぶものは何もないんだ
で 二番目 行為をするもの
させるものはいません
この我を否定してるんで
永遠不滅の魂を 私が行為をするに至って私が無いんだ
神様が行為させてるんだよと
そんなのはいませんよ
これ 個我と神我の否定だと思いますね
したがって行為には善果も悪果もありません
そんなことを言うならば
まああんた説法したっても意味がないんだよと
あんたのところで何か学ぶものは何もないんだよと
それでもう帰る羽目になるんです
はい  3番目は人は汚れる原因も清らかになる原因もありません
個人の努力はなりたたないという
これは明確に経典を読めば
昔の実際にあった宗教だからね
まあものすごく短冊してわかりやすくしてというような話でね
難しいんです これ哲学は
で あの特別に人を汚れ汚れる原因というのはないんだと
清らかにするというふうな原因はないんだと
だからここの清らかになるという原因なければ
いくら頑張っても心清らかにならない
心を汚れる原因もないならば
汚れないようにと頑張らなくたっても結構やという話です
原因否定するんですね
無縁無縁で 賢者も愚か者も定め
運命によって転生して終わるんだと
だから生命に定めがあるんだ
この定めによって決まっている回数を輪廻転生して
犬になったり 豚になったり
魚になったり ミミズになったり
王様になったり 定めた回数券があるんです
そこは全部終わったら終わりと
だから転生しているだけだと
こう言ってきた 一応転生は知ってる
認めるんです 知ってるんじゃなくて
しかしそれにはもう別に原因はないんだよというんです
それだったらその人のところ修業する必要はないでしょう
4番目の宗教 もっと科学的になってくるんです
地水火風 空楽命という絶対的に変わらない
影響を受けない 7つの元素で生命は構成されているんだと
絶対的存在である 7つの元素があるんだと
地水火風と空楽と命と
それはお互いには影響を与えませんと
だって絶対的だから人の影響を受けません
続きます 人は刀で人の首を切っても殺したことにはなりません
元素の間を他の元素が通っただけ
この 7つの元素はどうすることもできません
絶対に だから首を刀で切ったっても
元素には何もことも起きてないんだ
だから殺したことになりません
これさらに説明してね
糸巻きを転がすと 糸の長さまで転じて止まるように
賢者も愚か者も様々な生を得てから終わるんだよ
これちょっとダブってるみたい
別な経典ではもっと明確にこの哲学をまとめていますけど
こちらでこの仏教は人の宗教を批判する場合は
このわざと間違ったことを言わないで
本人が言っていることを言うんです
しかし 仏教では仏教なりのキャタライゼーションというシステムがあるんです
だから あるカテゴリーに人の教えを入れる場合は
あの人の教えの 4分の一と
この人の教えの 3分の一と
あの人の教えの 8分の一が同じものやと一緒のところに入れちゃう
入れて他宗教はこんなことを言うんだよって読んでいると
わからなくなっちゃうんです
具体的に歴史的に誰が教えたっていうこと
こっちに混ぜているんで
似ているものを 例えば私にしても
私はユダヤ教であろうとイスラム教であろうとキリスト教であろうと
同じやるでしょ 絶対的な神を信じてるんだから
だから言ってるポイントは同じだったら
みんなを一緒にまとめちゃうという仏教的なやり方なんです
だからこちらでちょっと混ぜてます
他の他の人の教えも同じく
なぜかというと 聞いただけでも宗教では宗教ならすというふうなことを言いたいんです
まあそれは皆様 インド学をやっているならば興味があるかも
でなければ忘れてください
それから納得がいかない宗教もあります
これも 4つあります 一切智者であると名乗る宗教家がいる
起きていても寝ていても一切をすでに知っていると説く
この場合は明確にジャイナ教のことを指しているんです
で 一切智者がいるんだ
ジャイナ教の教祖の中
自分が一切智者だとずっと言ってるんです
私は起きていたでも寝ていたっても全部知っているんだと言って
見てみると しかし彼が旅に出ると迷子になったり
犬に牛に襲われたりするのです
人に道を聞いたり 人の名前を聞いたりもします
あなたの名前は？とかね
なんとか町に行きたいんですけど
どういうふうに行けばよろしいか聞いたりする
そうすると あれ おかしいな
何かということになる
それ本人に聞いたらこう答えるんです
それを聞くと 迷子になる予定でしたと
知ってました この道で行って右に曲がったら迷子になるってことは全部前述時点で知ってました
だったらアホ なんで行ったんですかね
この人の名前は聞くことになっていました
そんなことはいい加減で
これ納得いかんと あなたの教えはということ
2番目 伝説 伝承 聖典などに基づいて語る
何についてま 聖書を開けて
だらだらだらだら聖書を引用しながら喋ると
インドでそういう宗教もあったんですよ
大量の聖書があって これ丸暗記して
何かあったらあちらでこう書いてます
こちらでこう書いてますとかね
あるいは本当に聖書がなくても
神の言葉ということは伝承されてあると
で 我々うちの伝承では神様がこう言った言ったとか
そればっかり喋ると これは納得いかないんですよ
なぜかというと 正しく伝承を受けたかもしれませんし
聞き違いあるかもしれませんしね
聖書ってこれ本当か また嘘かもとかね
神が言ったと誰かが言ったかなとかね
納得いかんですよ はっきりしましょうがないのが
個人の言葉だけに頼ることは納得いきません
だから昔の人はこう言いましたよと
それはもう我々もよく責められてるでしょ
昔はこういうことでしたから
だからあんたもやりなさいと
それって僕は納得いかんと
それはいいこと かもしれませんし
悪いことかもしれませんし
今更どうでもいいかもしれませんし
まあ例えば何でしたっけ？
お葬式なんかに行ったら
もうちょっと塩をかけてそれで清めると
みんな納得してやってますね
それで清めますかね あれ
あの葬儀屋さんが小さな袋に入れて塩をくれたみたいに
私は日本に 20年ですけど
一回しか葬式に行ってないんです
まあ二回行ったことはあるんですけど
それはまあちょっと友達の葬式でね
そこはまあ日本式ではなくて
まあ別のやり方でやりましたからね
塩もらわなかったんです
だから あれで清めます
清めますから しかし 昔個人はそう思っていたでしょ
だからそれは知ってます
で 個人はそう思ったんだからといって
だったらこれは確実に正しいってこと言えますかね
汚れないったらまずいんですかね
逆に葬式に行って 何がどうやって汚れるんですかね
具体的じゃないでしょ
これが汚れたったら その汚れに対処した清め方がないとダメでしょ
そうでもないんです だから日本では塩は清めだと思っていますけど
あの まあ古い話だからね
納得いかないだけ 嘘か本当かちょっといいね
例えば我々インド文化だったら水なんですね
清水だけではなくて 水に
あの あの 料理に使うターメリックありますね
まあ日本でいうウコンなんですけどね
そこをちょっと潰して入れちゃう
入れる 入れる それで体
顔とかね 洗ったりする
あれで清めますから しかし
ターメリックとウコンっていうのはものすごい殺菌力があることは確かなんです
すごい どんな汚れがあっても
ちょこっと来るとすごい綺麗になりますよ
顔も匂いもなくなっちゃって
だから昔の葬式っていうのはもう細菌だらけだから
病気で死んだかわからないし
病気で死んだって神罰やって死んだって言うでしょ
だからビールはダラダラからあっちこっち浮いてるし
それで人が行っても人にもうつりますから
やっぱり汚れたと だからもう一生懸命体洗いましょうと
昔の人は決めたかも でも現代ではね
まあ別な考え方でも通じるでしょう
だからこの個人の聖書の話ばっかり持ってくると
今日はこれはあんまり信頼できません
納得いかないな こちらで修行しても正しく善悪判断できるとは思いません
曖昧です 面白いことっていうのは
本当にいまだに宗教の世界で善悪判断すごく曖昧なんです
人殺すのは悪いですけど
悪いんです しかし 神を侮辱する人をやっぱり神を守ってあげなくちゃいけないんだというんです
そうすると 人殺すのはどうやって成り立つのですかね
さあ ある宗教家が何を語っても論理ばかりで単なる論理学者なんです
理屈ばっかり言うんですよ
理屈っていうのはいくらでも言えるんです
論理学だけでは その通りであるかもしれません
違うかもしれません 例えば論理学でのシンボリックロジックという学問があるでしょう
数学と同じくシンボルを並べ替えて論理するんです
あれって見事な論理なんですけど
実際の世界では一つも成り立たないんです
頭で考えて複雑な論理を作るんです
数字でシンボル だから実証する必要あります
シンボリックロジックのように実証することはないんですね
この宗教家が この教えで指導する気にはならないと決めるんです
ただ理屈ばっかりだから
本当にやったらどうなる？そうなるのかと
ないんだから そうやって全く宗教にならない宗教 4つと
曖昧で納得いかない 修行する必要ない宗教
また 4つがあると  4番目
また宗教家が不可知論者である
知ることは不可能ですと
もしかするとこの人は無知で何も知らないかも
結論に至らないかも ただ
自分がいくら考えたっても
世の中いろんなこと言うんだけど
論があったらどうしても反論があるでしょ
どんなテーゼもアンチテーゼもっているんだから
もうどうにもならんですよ
世の中は それ考えたら困ったもんで
やっぱり知っていうのは不可能だよ
と言える ただ それまた知恵でしょ
その人 それも言わないんです
不可知論者なんですけど
だからそっちで修行したらどうなるんですかね
どうにもならないんです
この人の下で修行しても何の意味もありませんということ
では一旦ちょっと休憩して
仏教の教えになります
では ご覧になろうと思います
えーと あまりこのわからない興味のないところは別にあの頭の中で飛ばしては構いません
はい それから仏教の修行はどういうことかと
実証できる教えで 実証できる道
教えだけではなくて この方法も
あ こうやればこうなるんだっていうことは
誰にでもわかるようになっているんです
結果を出した人々も無数にいる
お釈迦様にある話し方
他の宗教の人が来て これも中部経典にあってね
話を聞いたらすごいことやと
それでですね この悟りに達した人はね
あんただけ あんたは弟子も達しているんですかと
在家の男性の比丘たちに一人でも一人二人じゃないんだよと
20人  50人でもないんだよ
100人  200人でもない
もう 500人以上いますよ
あ わかりました では 阿闍梨さんの中で一人でもいますか？女性の出家
それで同じく 500人単位で数えなくちゃいけないんです
たくさんの人がわかった
だから在家男性の信者さんで
在家ではここまでというリミットはありますからね
その最高に達した人々は何人いるのかといったら
またお釈迦様は 500何 500人単位で
では女性は在家の これはまた結構になる
そう言われると言われたら
その人はこう言うんですよ
あなたの教えはもう完璧ですけど
もし自分以外誰も経験出てなかったら
その時点で不完全になる
しかし 在家の出家の男性も出家の女性も
在家の男性も在家の女性も
誰でも修行する人は悟りに達するんだから
まあ私には文句はありませんと
一応 ことはちゃんと実証しているんだよ
完全に そういうことだから
まあ私にも出家いただきたい
していただきたいな お釈迦様はあんな違う宗教の人だからね
仏教はあまり仏教に浸透するってことはしないんです
放っておくんです 人のこと
あんな違う宗教の人だから
それでも出家したいというならば
プロベーションがありますよ
いわゆる見習い時期があるんだ
資格を調べると それは 3ヶ月とかかかりますよ
と言ったら この人は しかし
私はね お釈迦様は特権を持ってます
私は人の顔を見てね そんな気張りやっても好き勝手に変えますよって
私はそれでも人の顔を見ますよと言われたら
お釈迦様は免除してあげたかったんです
この人は いえ お釈迦様が 3ヶ月間見習い修行の時期だというならば
私は 3年間やります  3年間やってから
私のことを真面目であること証明してから出家お願いしますと言って
3年間は見習いやったんです
3ヶ月間にその それから出家して
ずっとお釈迦様に会えないと都会行ってね
修行して ものすごく完全に大阿羅漢に達したんです
達したらそこら辺でなんか他の人たちを歩いてみて
あんた方どこに行くのかというと
もう長滝をしてブッダに会いに行きますよ
じゃあだったら私もお釈迦様に礼をして行ってくださいと行って
あの 私の仕事終わりましたと
お釈迦様に報告してください
はい わかりました と言ってお坊さんたちは
お釈迦様にそれ言う前に
いえ 私知ってますよと
彼がかなり超能力も含めて阿羅漢になっているということは知っていますよということで
阿羅漢になりましたという話になります
だから たくさん人々がやっぱりその通りやっていることは証拠があります
生きている間で教えは正しいか否かは確かめられますので
自信を持って修行ができるんです
だからまあ やってみたら結果がなかったらやめればいいでしょう
だから試しにやるということなんです
仏教は 中部経典の第1話は沙門果経ですね
今ここで得られる修行の結果というテーマなんです
そのテーマで長い経典があるんですよ
仏教の果報は今すぐ得られますよと
で 悟りに達する境地まで書いています